[موسيقى]
نتفاوض معها للحديث بعد ان تملكها ارتياب
وتردد
قبل سنه
داعشيه البلجيكيه وزوجه احد قاده التنظيم
المقتولين في الرقه تتحدث بثقه مع العربيه
عن قصتها كاول امراه تخلع النقاب في مخيم
روش
[موسيقى]
هيئتها تغيرت وقبضه خلايا التنظيم اشتدت
وان امتنعت عن تفسير تحولها هذا
مختلف من بره بس من جوا ما غير شيء يعني
ماذا تقول ما
بدي نحكي من هذا
كانت رؤيه الكثيرات يتجولن دون غطاء راس
ممكنه هناك لكن اليوم 30 فقط بقينا دون
حجاب او نقاب ريان واحده منهن تقول انها
تعرضت للتهديد وعرضوا عليها اموالا
[موسيقى]
من مخيم روج انتقل الى الهول الاخطر على
الاطلاق
المواجهه الامنيه مع تنظيم داعش كانت اكثر
حصما ووضوحا لكن مواجهه فكره وارثه معركه
اخرى لم تحسم بعد هنا في مخيم الهول في
الحسكه نسخه متجدده عن تنظيم داعش اصغر
ولكنها ليست اقل تطرفا فلتنظيم هنا ممولون
خلايا التجنيد والتدريب كما له قوانينه
ومحاكم
الحسابات مختلفه هنا وكلها تخضع لقوانين
داعش ترهيب ما لا يلتزم بقوانين التنظيم
وحرق خيانهن او ايذاءهن جسديا هذه الصور
كافيه لشرح ما يحدث اربع نساء احتجزهن
التنظيم وقيدهن بالسلاسل في مركز تعذيب
اقيم سرا داخل مخيم الهول
[موسيقى]
لا تتوقفوا نساء داعش عند التعذيب العام
الماضي شهد المخيم مقتل 36 شخصا بينه
فتاتان مصريتان اكتشفت جثتهما في مجاري
الصرف الصحي حوادث كشفت عن دور المحوري
للنساء داخل خلايا التنظيم بينها تهريب
السلاح
اسمه محمد احمد طلب مني اجيب له من محل
ابو عمار خلاطنا الفواكه
رحت جبتليهم بعد ما وصلتها
فتحت ترمز طالع منه المسدس بعد ما طالع
المسدس قال لي
تودي له المكان شخص قال توديني علي اسمه
نور بعد ما طلعت
تهريب اخذتها المسدس وراحت وديته على
الشخص اسمه نور بعد فتره تم توقيفي من قضى
الجهاز امن العام
لم يقتصر نشاط نساء داعش داخل حدود مخيم
الهول فالتحقيقات كشفت ايضا انهن حلقه وصل
رئيسيه لتنسيق هجمات التنظيم
حمله التمشيط الاخيره حتى الهجوم على سجن
صناعه
المعلومات المتوازي لدينا انه
الذكاء يقوم با يعني الاتصال ما بين السجن
وخارج السجن كانت امراه من ضمن المخيم
وضعت في الفتره الاخيره يعتمد على النساء
اكثر يقومون باخفاء الاسلحه الذخيره
او المنشورات
ويتحركون بشكل افضل
حتى عن طريق الانترنت يقوم بالتواصل
ارسلت تعليمات من والى ضعف
في مخيم الهول قصص لا تنتهي هذا قسم
مستحدث يسمونه المنطقه الامنه ينقل اليه
من يثبت ان حياته في خطر بسبب تهديد خلايا
داعشه
[موسيقى]
جنب مسجد
الثاني ولمن يضربوا حدا
رصاص نسمع صوت
الفجر مشان الناس
تنفذ امام المسجد يعني بعيد شويه يعني
الخطر يبقى قائما في مخيم تنشط فيه خلايا
داعش وتسعى لكسر قيود الاحتجاز واعاده
تنظيم صفوفها ساره بن عيشوبه العربيه من
شمال شرق سوريا